alors figurez-vous que que donc la gaffe
a participé à la classe et visiblement
visiblement et ben il est dedans contre
vous on va regarder j'ai lu en arrivant
que j'étais embrouillé pour être
embrouiller il faut être deux
amorcez pas avant c'est comme l'amour
d'accord c'est pas tout tout de suite
attendons la fin regardez je l'emmenais
bosser sur le sur le porte-bagage de mon
de mon 103 peugeot on a vraiment ramé on
a fait les 400 coups on a galéré et puis
quand ça a bien marché on est parti en
gala ensemble en Belgique en Belgique
j'ai beaucoup emmené en voiture on a
beaucoup fait de sketchs ensemble on a
partagé du pingouin et puis un jour ben
il pète un plomb il dit aussi Vincent
vient dans cette émission je viens pas
donc je l'appelle je dis mais il se
passe quoi Jean-Marie et là il me dit
ouais tu comprends dans ton bouquin tu
as été me dire que tu m'avais appris le
métier je peux pas accepter ça j'ai dit
mais Jean-Marie j'ai jamais écrit le
bouquin
donc il y a eu un silence et puis ouais
c'est vrai qu'on se parle moins
maintenant après je pensais que j'avais
un pote je pensais que j'avais un ami et
puis ben non c'est une relation
rien rien c'est que lui peut-être c'est
une envie de baiser
et une envie de baiser ça se respecte tu
vois mais peut-être qu'il a envie de
vendre son livre qu'il a
vraisemblablement pas écrit d'ailleurs
et donc voilà je sais pas de quel
embrouille la dernière fois que j'ai vu
Vincent Lagaf' j'ai eu le contraire
salué l'amitié qu'on avait ensemble
c'était une émission avec du bowling on
jouait à strike
et je l'ai vu j'ai préparé par Cyril
Hanouna je suis content de te revoir mon
vieux copain c'est tout nos carrières se
sont séparées il a fait lui une
brillante carrière d'animateur sur TF1
tout le monde lui a envie encore les
scores qui qui faisaient à 19h non pas
moi non mais quand même une carrière
magnifique et c'est tout et donc il
s'est strictement rien bien passé 0 je
vois pas d'où il me sort que un jour
j'ai dit de quoi je sais pas d'où ça
sortez le pain noir ensemble et quand le
pain est devenu plus blanc ça a été pas
partagé
plus blanc pour lui que pour moi parce
que quand il était embauché présentait
le 19 le 19h de TF1 il a fait un succès
monstrueux pendant beaucoup de temps
avant que moi-même je perce de mon côté
en écrivant des spectacles tu vois donc
je ne vois pas d'où ça sort le truc si
ce n'est que il a envie d'avoir une
embrouille avec Jean-Marie Bigard
peut-être que ça sert la vente de son
livre j'en sais rien je ne sais pas il a
écrit un livre ou pas parce que là il a
pas écrit de livres alors oui
ah bah voilà son livre bah oui bah voilà
mais l'autre jour très étonnant
Jean-Marie quand même c'est qu'il cite
des éléments factuels alors je dis pas
qu'il a raison mais c'est l'inspecteur
la bavure
il dit que vous refusiez par exemple de
sur scène il y avait un numéro un numéro
2 que vous exigiez de pas passer après
lui etc parce que c'était dur
tout à fait oui il a sorti ça de je sais
pas où le pauvre et voilà moi ça me fait
de la peine parce que on avait j'ai
toujours gardé une bonne relation
d'amitié avec Vincent et puis tout d'un
coup j'apprends en arrivant là sur ce
plateau que je suis embrouillé avec lui
on est vraiment avons voulu il vous en
veut vraiment
voulu je sais pas il faudrait encore
apparemment
mon cher Vincent je ne sais pas ce qui
est quelle mouche tu as piqué je sais
pas si jamais je t'ai fait du mal un
jour il y a 35 ans excuse-moi et puis
voilà je sais pas si ça fera vendre ton
bouquin d'aujourd'hui
il y a un principe maintenant de
promotion qui est bien connu
sur quelqu'un alors soit vous tapez sur
Cyril
par 1000 mais si vous tapez sur un ou
deux chroniqueurs un peu connu ça fait
ça fait de la reprise exactement donc ça
donc ça peut aider mais c'est vrai qu'il
est en promo il balance par exemple il
avait il avait fait l'émission de France
qui est en direct quelle époque quelle
époque et on va regarder il avait parlé
pas le match justement et ça a été
beaucoup repris
je pense qu'elle a mis si je vous dis
chauffard est accident de voiture est-ce
que vous pensez à votre film avec le
Palmashow ou au fait qu'en ce moment
pour Palmade c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
vous dites vous vous dites vous avez
commencé avec lui Pierre Palmade
on n'a jamais été des amis mais on a
commencé ensemble à la classe je l'ai
emmené faire des premières parties en
Belgique et dans le monde c'est
dramatique ce qui lui arrive mais foutez
lui la paix
ce qu'il a fait aussi est dramatique ce
qu'il a fait mais foutez lui
il y a rien rien à dire juste laisser la
justice faire ces choses et n'en
rajoutez pas alors on en parle tout à
l'heure de Palmade parce qu'on parle de
Big BD qui a un livre aussi qui sort
mais pour le coup dans cette séquence-là
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé plutôt courageux
dans cette séquence